good evening and thank you for joining
us tonight at 11 o'clock i'm sasha
loftis we now know the identity of a man
killed in the northwest valley yesterday
the las vegas review journal confirming
it was one of their own jeff german was
found dead with stab wounds outside his
home around 10 30 yesterday morning mary
jane belliesa shares how colleagues are
remembering him
it's a huge loss for the journalism and
las vegas community those who knew jeff
german say he was an established
journalist and his work made an impact
across the valley we don't know what the
motive is yet steve sebelius from the
review journal describes his colleague's
death as shocking i woke up to a bunch
of texts from people
i had no idea
how it had happened what had happened i
read a story in the rj and yeah shocking
is the word i'm still shocked by it
investigative reporter jeff gearman was
found dead with stab wounds outside his
home saturday morning he covered news in
the valley for decades while working at
the las vegas sun and las vegas review
journal sibelius first met gearman back
in 1993 and describes his friend as
ambitious and a self-starter he also
you know was adaptable you know they say
you can't teach an old dog new tricks he
was 69 years old and he was learning how
to do a podcast
and you know adapting like he was a
millennial so it was it was really
amazing to see him you know go off into
new ways of telling stories our own ron
futrell says german's tenacity to get
the top story made him bold and i get it
that not everybody is going to like
what a what an investigative journalist
does we have them here in our newsroom
and not everybody is going to be happy
with what they do when he was like that
but he didn't care he just wanted to get
things right and put it in the right
context futral knew gearman well they
worked closely together investigating
the removal of jerry tarkanian as unlv's
basketball coach there are so many
questions right now we don't know
answers to stuff but i'll tell you jeff
was fearless
that's one thing he was you can't do
some of the stories he did without being
fearless in that sense we spoke to
german's neighbors who didn't want to be
on camera they say they didn't know
gearman and didn't see anything
suspicious but offered their condolences
metro police say they do believe a fight
led to german stabbing they say they are
still looking for the suspect but they
do have a lead reporting from buffalo
and vegas drive mary jane valeza 8 news
now
in a statement from the review journal
executive editor and senior vice
president glenn cook he says quote jeff
gearman was as competitive relentless
trusted and accomplished as any reporter
in nevada over the past four decades he
broke big stories and developed
impactful investigations across every
part of southern nevada life from
politics to sports local and state
government to courts and business to
organize crime he will be terribly
missed by his family and colleagues and
we are all in shock over his senseless
killing his loss is unfathomable and he
is irreplaceable